very recently and and seemingly only
recently has the government acknowledged
the existence of UFOs they're real and
that is uh objectively incredible but
what I find more incredible is the fact
that when the government comes out and
says UFOs are real seemingly nobody
cares nothing it nothing changed like
like like and uh it's just like just
life goes on like I just you know now
you're obviously a lot closer to it and
so I'm sure that like a lot did change
in your view but me being just a Layman
guy like sort of I just don't it's it's
amazing to me I'm like how wait hold on
a second does nobody care yeah and and I
guess that's my first question
is is that your experience that wow like
I thought this was going to kind of make
more of a splash than it did yeah uh no
I didn't think it would make more of a
splash you know uh it is this kind of
slow absorption process of what does
that even mean there's a lot to talk
about what you just said so the
government acknowledged that UFOs are
real they call them UAP um unidentified
anomalous phenomena because UFO was in
lie of flying saucer which is originally
kind of what everybody was called him
because it was misunderstood a guy said
when he saw it Kenneth Arnold Mount
reneer this was
1948 I believe 47 I'm not good with
dates he said it it it moved like a if
you took a saucer and skipped it on
water so the media was like oh Flying
Saucer right but really the craft
weren't shaped at all like saucers the
ones that he saw so what happened is we
go into this term of UFO cuz it was
better it was unidentifed flying object
okay great but now we know they're under
the water they're in space like this is
documented so unidentified anous
phenomena is the new government term So
when you say the government acknowledged
that is correct our government has said
UFOs are
real they do fly with impunity within
our restricted airspace we don't know
who made them they appear we don't know
who operates them and they appear to be
able to do things that our own weapon
systems can't
our greatest fighter planes canned the
way they man the way they maneuver and
stuff so you're right they've said UFOs
are real we're no closer to
understanding what a UFO truly is who
operates them where are they from what's
the intent what they represent to
humankind so the public in general they
see that [__] on the news it's like okay
yeah we all kind of thought that cuz
we're seeing them thanks government
right but nothing's really answered um I
I think that from my perspective um
changing the name from UFO to UAP
unidentified anomalist phenomenon uh
makes a lot of sense because
like why would these things even
assume uh a physical form when they're
like aren't they by definition
interdimensional things I don't know see
that that's the thing now we're starting
to get to the areas of like what is a
UFO what does this whole phenomenon
represent to humankind is it more than
just machines or craft so you just said
interdimensional let me give you a few
other theories people have so one is
like interplanetary so you're like
extraterrestrial so these are craft
coming from other solar systems from
within our galaxy or maybe Beyond Zeta
reticuli sure the famous Zeta reticuli
binary star system that Bob Lazar
brought into the Forefront through he
read that he doesn't even know if it's
true yes so you've got that idea
extraterrestrial then you have this one
you said which is interdimensional which
is like so interesting because I can't
jokingly can't even live in this
Dimension I don't know I'm not smart
enough to understand what that means but
right the way it was described in
Congress recently which I'm sure we'll
talk about is like you can take a
three-dimensional object hold it up to a
light project a two-dimensional Shadow
against the wall right kind of like
Plato's Cave that allegory whatever so
when you see something that might be of
a higher Dimension coming into existence
in our dimensional reality you're only
seeing like a representation of it it's
like if you push an orange
three-dimensional sphere through a
two-dimensional plane on that
two-dimensional plane people will just
see a growing Circle and then a fading
Circle that's what they can perceive on
that dimensional reality So when you say
it's it could be all you know
extradimensional that's some of the
greatest scientists now who take this
seriously believe it could be so why
would they even present themselves if
they have this super stealth mode these
crap so let's go further than that right
I mean that's the question is that like
they don't I would assume they don't
have any need to uh take a physical form
to be perceivable by us so it would like
presumably be a choice that they appear
when I would guess they don't have
totally so but let's go a little further
with that into other possibilities this
could be cuz remember the true
architects of this secrecy it's not your
government it's whoever the visitors are
themselves if they're in fact visitors
and not from here originally right so
whoever is operating these craft if
these are hard physical craft they could
reveal themselves so there's an intent
but we just don't know what it is so
we've got interdimensional
extraterrestrial now there's one called
extratemporal which is sorry
extraterrestrial just by definition
means not from Earth not from this world
from outside of the world yeah from
somewhere else right so the better would
be non-terrestrial would the way that I
that I would say people say e
extraterrestrial you be non-terrestrial
right that'd be a good one so you got
that
extradimensional then you've got this
idea of uh extemporal so the way that a
lot of the scientists that I talk with
who've been working on this problem for
government and within Private Industry
say these are gravitationally propelled
we don't know much we don't know
anything about gravity we can observe
its effects but we don't know what it is
or how to control it other than through
Mass so they say this could be extra
temporal because when you shape gravity
it distorts time and space so by
definition these craft are from another
time so you've got extemporal extra
dimensional extra terrestrial or
non-terrestrial then you have another
theory which is the idea that these have
always been here and and human beings
are just kind of tuned in now to like a
breakaway Civ civilization or some sort
of other people that have been here
before they're from here they've been
here under the oceans whatever in
Antarctica that's another theory people
like to to put forward is that this is
some sort of breakaway civilization that
been with us a long time then you keep
going you've got these ideas that this
is some sort of simulation so what we're
seeing what they're presenting are like
craft just ahead of what we have now so
we can then have a learning process of
trying to replicate
as if it's a techn terrestrial there's
another one the idea that we're all
evolving towards a technological goal
with a little bit of assistance from
others and I I love that one because
there's a lot of evidence that UFOs are
presented in their time in ways that
those people can understand them back in
the day when you say those people you're
not talking about humans no I I those
people of that time so it's like in the
1800s a lot of UF
okay got they looked like so those
people in the 1800s they saw
UFOs often times as kind of likees you
know but there was none at the time but
that was a technology about to come or
just budding so a lot of the UFO reports
are these like Viking floatable ships
with spotlights which we had nothing
like that at the time but you got
reports in multiple countries within
that four or five year period where
they're seeing that and now we've got
these craft that look Interstellar so
you have to ask yourself is the UFO
phenomenon [__] with us and are they
presenting whoever they are something
that we can relate to that's just
outside of our grasp to help Propel us
forward like a control system to educate
us or they only tend to show up in areas
where there's nuclear power and they're
watching us to make sure we don't [__]
up the Earth okay well let's get there
because the thing the thing is that
there there is an influx at all times
since we began the nuclear program since
1945 when we had the Trinity test site
explosion of the first nuclear weapon
you had an in UFOs existed before but
there's been a great interest u a kind
of increased frequency of activity
surrounding our nuclear assets including
these detonations now they haven't
stopped any of them but UFOs have come
into nuclear sites turned on and off
nuclear missiles a guy that lives close
to me is a friend of mine and he was
part of that he saw them go online
offline as a red disc came in over the
base now George knp found out through
documents that happened not only in the
US when he smuggled Russian UFO
documents back it happen in also in
Russia but it's not just like hey here's
your matches we're going to take them
from you they turned them [__] on too
so that's a kind of Flex if you ask me
so so the UFO thing and also our United
States government has what they call
baited UFOs before so on multiple
occasions in the transit of nuclear
weapons or bringing them out places like
CL award these things whatever they are
show up that's what I'm told and I
understand the facts to be so with that
said okay but help me with the baed part
yeah baited so like uh they were saying
to scientifically study UFOs we have to
have a repeatable process right you
can't just be like some guy saw one some
fighter pilot chased one so you're
saying that the United States government
in uh the interest of studying UFOs
effectively said troops load up the
nukes we got to transport them so that
it will uh draw the the UFOs so that we
can study them they would never tell the
troops
that put that container in the you know
but I mean yeah so it is understood by
me you know take that for what what it's
worth um my understanding is at this
time and I'm pretty damn confident with
it that uh we had had opportunities to
study the phenomenon scientifically by
trying to set up the environment where
UFOs would come and that would be by
baiting them by the movement of nuclear
weaponry and uh if that's true that's
pretty astounding it does show a
correlation with our nuclear weapons I
mean look maybe this planet is really
[__] cool and we're kind of like a
lower primate species and we're [__]
it up and so they're like you know let's
watch these [__] before they blast
something right I mean I I I would guess
and totally uneducated to that that all
of the um just call them entities
energies like that there there's that we
are just fascinating oh we have to be
we're entertainment for them hell yeah
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and and
sto's butt wipes for your butthole it's
the butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude